- I swear to God, this room is my tomb.
This is where I'll come to die,
in this frickin yoga mat room.
("Workin' Man")
I'm excited to like, get
back in the swing of things,
'cause I know my mood is going to improve.
- I mean, I know I'm gonna hate it.
There's no way around that.
- I'll go to bed earlier,
and my skin will get better.
- I'm most nervous about just
feeling like a walking corpse.
- The benefits of exercise
are, like, endless.
(alarm beeping)
- So I just woke up.
I'm totally gonna be late for work.
I have to go for a stupid run.
- Would it be weird,
or bad,
if I put cold brewed
coffee in my water bottle?
- I accidentally woke
up late this morning.
So now I'm rushing
to get back to my apartment
so that I can not look like
a slob when I go to work.
(alarm beeping)
- It is day two.
I just woke up,
and I hate this.
- I'm dying, man.
Three more days of this?
Fuck.
No.
(alarm beeping)
Meh.
I don't,
I don't feel great.
I'm showing up increasingly later to work
over the course of the week,
and I already show up late to begin with.
- Working out in the
morning is way different
than working out after work.
I feel stressed for time,
and I'm a lot more tired.
(alarm beeping)
- Getting up early
actually is getting easier,
which is shocking.
- I'm Feeling better.
I guess this has been kind of rewarding.
Physically or whatever.
Pretty sure I'm gonna be at work like,
only like 15 minutes late today.
Which is like,
me being 15 minutes early.
(alarm beeping)
- I feel pretty good.
I don't feel as tired as I usually do.
- Do it. (groans)
- In the beginning I was
definitely way more tired,
even though I worked out in the morning.
And then towards the
end I did start to feel,
I think, better, I dunno.
The difference was so subtle,
but it did get easier to wake up early.
- So I think the hardest part was
just change I guess.
The harder...
Like I didn't know how
hard it would be to just
change something that I do every day.
I ate breakfast.
This forced me to eat breakfast.
- No, I would not do this again.
Yeah, health, whatever that matters,
but,
nah.
I hated it.
I hated it, I hated all of it.